Another type of conclusion you
might want to be able to draw,
is to say that if you change one thing,
another thing is likely to change also.
For example, you saw that students
who passed the first project
are more likely to visit the classroom
multiple times in their first week.
This is a correlation.
Passing the first project is
correlated with visiting the classroom
multiple times.
Does this mean that visiting the
classroom multiple times in the first
week causes the students
to pass their project?
This would be a statement of causation.
For example, suppose Udacity sent emails
to students during their first week
reminding them to come back.
This caused more students
to visit multiple times.
Would you expect this to increase
the number of students who complete
their project?
It certainly sounds plausible, but
we can't be sure based on this data.
To see why,
let's take a look at this graph,
which shows per capita
cheese consumption in red.
And the number of people
who died by becoming tangled
in their bedsheets in black.
As you can see, these two
variables are highly correlated.
As one increases,
the other tends to increase as well.
However, do you think eating
cheese causes people to become
tangled in their bedsheets?
Probably not.
This could be a coincidence or there
could be some third factor causing both.
In this case, it looks like
both cheese consumption and
bed sheet tangling
are increasing over time.
If this is the case,
then if you banned cheese,
bedsheet tangling would probably
continue to increase overtime.
So what are some third factors that
could be causing the correlation
between visiting the classroom and
passing projects?
One that I thought of
is level of interest.
Maybe people who don't find the data
analysis courses very interesting,
don't visit the site many times.
And then they also don't pass the
project because they're not interested
in working on it.
If you somehow convinced these students
to visit the site more, their lack of
interest might still prevent them
from working on the project.
A better approach might be for
the student to try learning something
else that they find more interesting.
Another factor might be
background knowledge.
Maybe some people don't have the
programming knowledge they need to take
the data analysis courses and
they get stuck and don't come back.
If you convince these
students to come back and
keep trying, they might remain stuck and
not be able to make forward progress.
In this case, a better solution might be
taking a programming course to fill in
the missing background knowledge.
On the other hand, this correlation
could be because of causation.
And I actually find that
explanation pretty plausible.
But the point is that we don't
know based on the data we have.
To find out whether one change causes
another, you need to run an experiment,
and online experiments
are frequently costed A/B tests.
To learn more about how to
set these experiments up and
some common gotchas that can arise check
out Udacity's course on A/B testing
linked in the instructor's notes.